et qu'olivier de la marche économistes
bonsoir olivier delamarche merci d'être
avec nous un cours du pétrole qui a
chuté hier sous la barre des 0 $ on a du
pnr du pnl croire un niveau jamais
atteint jamais atteint par don jusque là
votre réaction
bonsoir bah écoutez le réaction s'est
fait assez amusé parce que j'ai
l'impression personne n'a compris en
fait qui s'était passé
c'était simplement les futures qui était
à l'échéance
lundi soir et donc vous aviez plein de
nouveaux investisseurs qui se sont
retrouvés lundi en pleine panique parce
qu'ils avaient acheté le baril sur les
futures qui se terminait il avait acheté
le baril
et tout d'un coup on leur annonçait que
on allait leur livrer les bars il est
évidemment le petit trader dans son
studio de 20 mètres car elle si vous
voulez qui c'est qui tout d'un coup
c'est dit qu' il allait avoir deux mille
barils chez lui ça l'a un peu affolés et
donc il a vendu et il a vendu à ce
moment là à n'importe quel prix mais il
faut bien différencier deux choses le
pétrole physique qui lui depuis un bout
de temps et vendu déjà largement en
dessous de 20 dollars suivant d'où il
vient
d'accord et et le ce qui se passe sur
les marchés financiers qui est en
quelque chose de purement technique si
vous voulez donc et on a bien vu à ce
moment là que par exemple le brent n'a
pas suivi pourquoi pourquoi le brent
laing pas suis tout simplement parce que
le brent vous pouvez à l'échéance des
futures sur le brent
vous pouvez être réglé en cash ou être
réglé en pétrole le wti en revanche vous
n'avez pas le choix
vous êtes automatiquement régler en
pétrole dont qui évidemment vous avez
des gens qui ont paniqué totalement qui
sauf trouver potentiellement livré en
pétrole
et ça il voulait pas on peut les
comprendre et à ce moment là ils ont
vendu massivement et et on sort on se
retrouve avec un futur pétrole 1 au tf
de pétrole qui aujourd'hui n'a pas coté
et je pense que ça va faire des pertes
gigantesques chez les courtiers
chez les banquiers qui ont spéculé sur
le sur le pétrole les prix du baril là
je reconnais de vous couper parce que au
moment où je vous parle le prix du baril
coté à new york a est repassé en clôture
au-dessus de 0 à 1 10 dollar est ce que
ça veut dire que vous êtes en train de
vous ou bien finalement c'est un
micro-événement techniques auxquelles on
apporte aux événements mais bien sûr que
c'est un micro événement c'est à dire
que vous avez 7 cette échéance des
futures mais si si vous alliez le même
jour hier
vous vouliez acheter du pétrole vous
alliez le payer plus de 20 dollars le
baril sur l'échéance de juin
donc arrêtons de ce2 ce2 se prendre la
tête là dessus ce qui est vrai en
revanche c'est économiquement
aujourd'hui le pétrole vous le payez sur
des sur des zones qui sont extrêmement
basses et que ça ça va je pense que ça
va dans les mois qui viennent
complètement détruire tout le pétrole de
schiste aux états unis pourquoi tout le
pétrole de schiste aux états unis tout
simplement parce que le pétrole de
schiste c'est un pétrole qui coûte cher
à sortir du sol
vous avez des coûts de production qui
ont qui sont entre 50 et 70 dollars le
baril et donc quand vous sortez quelque
chose du sort 70 dollars le baril et que
vous le vendez 20 évidemment ça fait mal
ça fait très très mal et donc vous avez
tous le tout pétrole de schiste qui est
en train de faire faillite
avec tout l'écosystème qui avait autour
de ce pétrole de schiste
ce sont les laits des villes quasiment
entière qui se sont construites autour
des puits de pétrole et qui aujourd'hui
avec tous les services qui sont associés
et qui aujourd'hui vont faire faillite
on a constaté une forte augmentation des
banques régionales des faillites de
banques régionales aux états unis qui
sont celles qui avaient prêté au pétrole
de schiste et je vous dis là aujourd'hui
le l'événement d'hier va faire très
probablement des gros trous de chez des
courtiers
chez des traders est aussi probablement
dans des banques mais ça on le saura que
dans quelques que dans quelques mois
mais là c'est un événement qui est
purement financier qui concerne en rien
ce qui se passe sur le pétrole physique
en revanche elle pétrole physique
aujourd'hui on sait qu'on en a en
surabondance qu'on ne sait plus où
mettre que vous avez aujourd'hui les
stocks terrestres qui sont pleins à ras
bord et que on emploie depuis un certain
nombre de semaines
les tanks air qui sont open qui font des
ronds dans l'eau pour ce qu'elle pétrole
merci malheureusement s'il voulait plus
on a un pétrole qui est bas plus on va
avoir un problème de stockage
merci d'avoir été avec nous remercier
pour vos explications olivier delamarche
en direct sur rt francs